oh let's talk about that one then [ __ ]
okay that one show we did in the first
day I got sick the shitty show the
shitty venue shitty man yeah what a guy
who kept talking during I said oh no no
that's the deficit that was Cleveland
Cleveland okay yeah Cleveland Cleveland
I I kind of went in a little bit on my
last stream not really okay X I didn't
at all okay so this this yeah I mean the
venue was like I don't know whatever I
don't know has it I'm a dude it's it's
pretty bad it was a busted ass man it's
pretty [ __ ] bad and I said there's no
there's like no bathroom in the green
room ya know the bathroom is shared
wouldn't the with the public which I
guess like doesn't I don't know it sweet
like you you don't like go take a [ __ ]
next to someone right before your show
and yeah oh my god you're gonna bin
you're like yeah I've done every second
I'm diarrhea but yeah it there was that
I mean it's the venue or it wasn't in a
good area that's for sure
are you about to perform what are you
doing I'm getting all the calm out of my
ass got all this freaking [ __ ] in my ass
what am I gonna do with it this all even
get in there how does all this come get
in my ass tell me this is boring out
doesn't begin another roll in here I
just gotta get it all out of my ass come
in my ass has a friend that hurt ya
can't do that now
there's coming and cleaning all the car
sorry and I've got this [ __ ] in my ass
okay so we're doing a show of this venue
okay right away like right away the
sound guy acting a little bit funky
right off the bat I'll do it he looks
like a like a washed up boat mechanic
like he just does not good man old and
the soundcheck went very poorly
basically weird
as long as soundcheck we were had yeah
tested each mic one by one and then was
like was like had a sixth ringing the
mics in front of the speakers and stuff
usually this is all stuff that we don't
have to deal with mm-hmm
like testing the feedback and stuff like
that they all know how to do that
because they're all professionals yeah
like you just you wave it in front of
the like reference monitors once and any
other sound guys okay yeah yeah yeah
thanks that's it
he said keep waving it keep waving it
this is like keep waving it okay keep
wait okay so you want this mic on the
whole time
and we're like our mics yeah that'd be
great if they could be on the whole time
so it's a comedy show so how many okay
so gonna be on the whole time great
great okay so just wave it wave it and
then keep waving it the feedback is like
piercing it's like [ __ ] everybody's
yeah and wave it could you wave it dude
so there's that so whatever we get the
soundcheck done and we're like okay
alright that was painful but we got
through it and then Showtime we gave him
you know we give him the walkout song
and uh he instead decides to play keep
your dick fit no but first of all it
wasn't even that it was we were waiting
on stage that's like you ready and we're
like yeah and he says usually says were
ready and then he signifies the sound
guys sound got plays and music and so
between that between him saying you
ready and us going on use about 30
seconds okay maybe so we're like you
know we're ready we're ready to [ __ ]
go onstage so we're like let's do it you
know and in 20 seconds we go onstage
right so this time he goes you ready yep
signifies a sound guy nothing happens
for like two minutes what the [ __ ]
that's a quiz this guy doing good ready
nothing happens for another like minute
probably now we're like okay let's go
like now people we're late and finally
finally we hear dimly in the background
keep your dick fattest plain gorgeously
quietly - like not even loud quietly and
the crowd starts singing it and we're
like no no what no what is happening
yeah keep your dick yeah keep your dick
we're just like just the least cool way
ever
to come out to a show and then abruptly
he just plays the correct song at the
same volume yep
so then there's this weird transition
where we walk out and everyone's like
keep you did away what and then we're on
stage and was like oh yes yeah we're
like what the [ __ ]
so we go out there or trying to you know
you know we're opening up the show and
you know oh he doesn't stop the music so
we start talking to the crowd and he's
just still playing the music and
normally when that happens is okay maybe
didn't hear us we keep talking to the
crowd we keep talking on the crowd still
doesn't stop playing the music Tom had
to come out and go yeah get it down and
the guy gets it down like thank you and
I like I said to him toi some like let's
bring that music down bro let's bring
that music down and he just didn't take
the cue I'm like weird so then yes
there's that and then so we start doing
the show and then we get to a certain
part of our show where we like to do a
little song and so I say hey bro can you
the song starts playing by a turn at oh
man like just to bring the energy up and
he turns it up and we do the do the song
and it's fun and the song ends and then
this one foot gets on his mic and starts
talking to us through the reference
monitors in the weirdest softest
weirdest voice just like you know was
that was that was that loud enough did
that show and like coding there in the
middle of talking and then I just like I
had like a weird I think I'm going manic
I'm like like what the [ __ ] was that
yeah and then I'm just like I can't
believe and I turn around to our boy Tom
I'm like am I crazy I say that to him
I'm like am I crazy
and then Kody's like yeah boys yeah that
good the song was that the good volume
for the song it sound like Jack how's
that good boys is that good the volume
for the song there was a good boy that a
good level yeah and then we realize it's
him and we're like oh my god this guy's
just talking in the middle of our
[ __ ] set it's a show you can't just
[ __ ] just just talk I'm going crazy
and then like Cody likes and asked me
out of it he's like he's like it's the
[ __ ] sound guy and I'm like what
man you got jokes you wanna do it yeah
Cody's that you wanna come up here and
do some [ __ ] and then so then there's
that and we do show and uh you know
people are asking us to roast cities and
I might have to roast Cleveland a little
bit cuz that was a weird and hot ass
show but some of y'all I don't know if
you have a pulse man what does that mean
these dudes are looking back at us like
the [ __ ] like the cows they raised
man they're just sitting there staring
just chewing just like the holes of the
wall one hour I'm watching I'm watching
I look at the crowd I'm like this fool
has not moved like the whole show is
just [ __ ] it's funny too because
those are the dudes when you call them
out you are you haven't laughed once or
even fun they was about yeah they are
yeah yeah all right Joe and then you can
you can express it a night one we they
started chanting Oh H I Oh
oh you're right just weird we've not
encountered that anywhere else but it's
it's so weird how fast it is it's like
Oh H Oh like immediately immediately
it's like a reflex for them
yeah oh wait how like no time to [ __ ]
even we don't even know what's going on
yeah people just kept doing and then
it's just like it's like a whack-a-mole
thing where people like pop up
Ohi were like oh oh wait I'm just like
how do you sound guys oho yeah they're
no but look what happened during the Q
and hey yes and then yes I'm gonna get
next to so during the QA we're talking
to people you know calling on people
it's a fun like interactive thing and
then the more like a sound guy takes his
mic and she starts giving it to random
people I don't know where we're like
answering someone's question and his
[ __ ] dad is just like on the mic he's
like yes and we're like whoa what the
where is this coming from now and then
cuz I get super loud right away yeah and
then he just starts like he asked us
this question it was a fair question and
then dude just starts passing the [ __ ]
around random people and then Tom runs
out there again and he goes yo no not
cool and
stop it stop it imagine imagine that
you're doing a comedy show where you're
just supposed to have the only two mics
and all of a sudden now there's a third
bonus mic that's drifting around the
crowd imagine that just just a magic do
you want to turn yeah hi Cindy
I'm from Cleveland I'm a dentist I just
had a question so funny man this guy was
so out of it yeah it's been wasted or
something no he said Tom talked to him
and he's worked with him before he's
like hey man how you doing that uh the
guys like yeah I remember you I hurt my
back recently and then Tom's like this
threw some pills he's [ __ ] up oh yeah
okay he's like it's gonna be bad it's
gonna be bad
[Music]